well I think it's very disappointing
that the brexit process has now been
entrusted to Jeremy Corbyn and the
Labour Party and I think that the result
will almost certainly be if Corbin gets
his way that we remain in the customs
union so that we can't control our trade
policy the huge areas of lawmaking
we can't control and brexit is becoming
soft to the point of disintegration we
could be moving into a position with
Parliament where the majority in the
House of Commons calls the shots what
would you say to that well I think
Parliament should think about our
responsibilities they just think about
what people were promised in 2016 and
they should deliver a brexit that really
allows us to take back control of our of
our money our borders and our laws and
this really doesn't qualify because you
don't take back control of your laws and
you can't do free trade deals if you
remain in the customs union and I think
that people will feel very short changed
and they will be bitterly disappointed
it can't last
this approach cannot endure you cannot
expect the fifth biggest economy in the
world to come out of the EU and remain
run by the EU it's just not
democratically sustainable and for those
of us who campaigned for brexit and who
believe in it and who believe in the
opportunities of brexit it is bitterly
disappointing what I hope is that there
is still time for the prime minister to
get an improvement to the deal that she
has or just to get her existing deal
through which is frankly better now than
the chaos of having a Corbin controlled
Customs Union rested what do you say to
those who feel as soon as you do about
Brixton in your own party at Westminster
what should they do how should they
react should they make some move so
bringing about new management at the top
how on earth can we be proposing now to
delay brexit again with is that we've
had a wonder we missed the Marsha 29th
deadline we're gonna miss the April the
12th deadline we now run the risk of the
absolutely ludicrous absurdity of
contesting the European elections the
euro elections are cost about a hundred
million hundred nine million quid this
the government will have to spend to
elect 73 British euro and he's paid up
up to a hundred thousand pounds a year
for all sorts of allowances to do what
to sit in Strasbourg doing exactly what
manifesto will they will they stand for
election the thing is satirical now we
should be leaving
and we've made abundant preparations for
coming out without a deal I had hoped
that the cabinet would decide to go down
that route because the as you know that
withdrawal agreement has been defeated
three times you could manage a perfectly
set as apprentice herself has said you
could manage a perfectly successful
successful no deal outcome and I think
that is what the public wants is this
the time or is it too late for a change
of leadership for some move if it's
possible to change the leadership and if
that's the case are you one who would
wish to be the leader you could you
argue the party needs now what we need
to do is get breaks it done and I'll be
absolutely clear we also need a change
of approach and if we're gonna have a
second phase and I hope that we will
have a second phase if you get the the
first bit over and done with then we
cannot go on with a failure to decide
about these fundamental issues whether
to remain in the customs union or not
whether to stay aligned with EU single
market rules or not we need to take
those decisions move on and then start
to deliver on the issues that really
matter to the British
what about the idea of trying to bring
about a change at the top at this side a
brexit would that in your view be a good
idea well I think what everybody in the
country wants more than anything else in
the world is for politicians in
Westminster not to focus on themselves
were to focus on the needs of the
country the needs of the country now are
number one to get brexit done and to
come out of the EU and what we've heard
tonight is that there's going to be yet
more delay unacceptable delay there is
no need to extend the brexit process in
the way that we're seeing I think it's a
great shame that we've missed the
opportunity to come out at No Deal and I
as I say I think it is bitterly
disappointing that the climax of the
brexit process is now being entrusted to
Jeremy Corbyn and the Labour Party with
the result that were almost certainly
going to remain in the customs union